one of the most anticipated video games
in years is finally being released on
November 8th death stranding for
PlayStation 4 ok
death stranding has been shrouded in
mystery for literally years along with
its creator the video game genius Hideo
Kojima and yes when I was recently in
Tokyo shooting our Conan in Japan travel
show I got invited because of my
connections in the gaming world to meet
this is that's actually not a Joe is not
a joke one of the best laughs of the
night and I was telling the truth it was
I was invited to meet this very elusive
Hideo at his top-secret Kojima
production studio and get a sneak peek
at death stranding this is a huge deal
he let us bring our camera crew and it
was kind of exciting here's what
happened I am here in Tokyo at the very
very very top secret offices of Hideo
Kojima he's been working for a long time
on the most highly anticipated video
game maybe ever death
stranding this is an absolutely amazing
opportunity and a huge mistake on their
hand I'm here to see Hideo Kojima Conan
O'Brien I don't understand there's a
card swiped here I was not sent a card
let's see I have a triple-a card
what a Costco card work I have a Costco
card yes
oh my god
today Oh
[Music]
I hope we could see you later thank you
welcome I got home today oh just asked
me if I wanted to see his office in his
toy collection is this you huh yeah that
is really a good likeness
Thoma ultraman ultraman does something
oh that's a vibrator no no really
that's a vibrator someone gave a storm
as a prank he doesn't know yeah and then
what does Ultraman do doesn't Ultraman
do something to it that's the time
everyone is working on death stranding
we want to protect the secrecy of the
game so we are blurring everything
behind us I want to go the extra mile
here I'm going to blur you where yeah
I've just been told I am allowed to show
one thing they Kojima studios that
nobody has seen before so check it out
[Music]
hanging jackets next I got to watch a
game trailer for death stranding with a
day oh this is it here we go
what's wrong with you
there's Norman Reedus I make deliveries
he makes deliveries okay he's a delivery
man he's delivering a pizza and you know
what it's gonna be more than 30 minutes
oh wow this is the first shower Norman
Reedus has had in three years I'm
noticing that there are many scenes
where Norman is naked was that Norman's
request you know a monk erotica struck
home oh no no worry matamata civilian ah
Norman Norman asked for a better body
didn't it I've seen him naked and he
doesn't look like that wait a minute
that's guillermo del toro did he ask you
to change his body he's got a baby yeah
is the ultimate gamer fantasy if if you
can carry your own baby you never ever
have to worry about having sex with a
woman I think these are this is
absolutely stunning work
put on some demo stuff I could be in the
game
really oh we got a scam right now yeah
one thing it worries me and the camera
adds 10 pounds and there are 80 cameras
here this is mouth completely open eyes
open ready doctor anger watch this ready
[Applause]
that's also constipation so take your
pick
if there's a scene where I'm had a lot
of cheese over a three-day period that's
also my orgasm face who cares okay that
spot hold it go back go back
that spot right there is there a
dermatologist here let's admit it I have
a very good bone structure I could play
a great hero
[Applause]
maybe this will change your mind very
much I really appreciate it and I know
even after he caught me stealing
ultraman's vibrator today I was still
nice enough to put me in his game good
was threaded by the hand of my cosplay
partner wear it and you too can ride the
river rapids without fear unless you're
afraid of looking too sexy really still
nothing
[Applause]